il s'appelle bizarre il a des savates
des savates deux doigts le matin sur les
hauteurs du chef de la réunion souffle
un vent de francophonie
[Musique]
les enfants des écoles voisines les
centres de loisirs les classes
transplantées fréquente régulièrement ce
lieu tout comme les stagiaires
francophone de l'océan indien
c'est monsieur parent chercheurs ali et
nappez institut national de recherche
pédagogique qui était vice présidente de
l'afm association française pour la
lecture qui de passage dans l'île pour
exercer son métier d'inspecteur s'est
dit qu'il va falloir mettre en place un
centre où on préserve l'interculturalité
un lieu convivial où les parents
viennent accompagner les enfants pendant
un temps long une semaine en internat
pour qu'ils puissent voir comment
l'école fonctionne à l'intérieur
ne sachant pas g de semoule de maïs 125
g de beurre 125 g de shit ce cadre e s
à quoi ça sert de lit
maintenant 30 jours mais bien réfléchi
qu'est ce que c'est et tu n'as pas eu
des livres qui n'a pas aidé livre cette
vente à l'état la jeune homme
merveilleux passe par le contact du
livre avec des images qui parlent de
maurice de ces chèques de madagascar et
voilà les grands aident les petits la
magie opère
les led se mélangent aux mots et aux
animaux donc c'est un lieu qui marie
l'éducation formelle et l'éducation
informelle dans le but de maîtriser
d'aider les enfants à maîtriser la
langue française ici on a notre
exposition aimé césaire le père de la
négritude avec son ami sans gore c'est
un peu révélateur de ce que nous faisons
à savoir on accueille les gens dans leur
culture et pour avec tous ceux qui
partagent la langue
les mauriciens et seychellois donc la
dia l'océanie parce que le tampon on a
mis en place après la fermeture du
centre de formation bujumbura dans
l'afrique de l'est s'étaient pas pallier
à ce membre à la fermeture de ce centre
en afrique de l'est qu'on a ouvert le
tampon mais il y avait des échanges
entre les deux structures
parce que les les adultes qui venait de
l'afrique de l'est basé au tampon il
venait observer les enfants ici et ils
ont pris aussi la place dans les écoles
de tampon il allait enseigner sur place
dans l'école
[Musique]
non
le centre local de considération
internationale oeuvre donc pour le
renforcement de la langue française dans
la zone en afrique australe en afrique
orientale et également au travail dans
l'océan indien
nous menons des actions de formation en
direction des professeurs de français
langue étrangère en direction des
alliances françaises et ambassades
donc de la région donc là on est dans le
bureau d'al et charlotte elle seule qui
a bénéficié des formations de français
du cachet international par le passé qui
aujourd'hui est chargé de programme chez
nous au centre local via les réseaux
d'alliance francophones et avec
l'accompagnement du département oms et
huy ou en volontaire de solidarité
elle a connu madagascar le mexique
taïwan l'australie et l'afrique du sud
après avoir été bénéficiaire aujourd'hui
développe les programmes pour la
francophonie a fait maintenant plus de
six ans est donc maintenant je travaille
sur des projets justement pour
développer la francophonie
là on travaille sur un projet avec le
kenya dont qui consiste à former des
enseignants de français dans le primaire
et le secondaire
donc on sera amené à envoyer des experts
de l'île de la réunion au kenya suis
très fier d'avoir bénéficié de ces
dispositifs de coopération
internationale avec le département du
valle a réunion est aujourd'hui en être
actrice la dynamique de la francophonie
à la réunion est très particulière car
elle réunit autour de la table beaucoup
d'interlocuteurs
le centre local de france et du cassiot
internationale mais également
l'université la réunion qui nous héberge
l'académie de la réunion qui met à
disposition des postes mais également
mobilise des experts et des intervenants
est également d'autres établissements
d'enseignement supérieur donc c'est tout
un écosystème en faveur de la langue
française qui agit ici à la réunion
en temps normal cet outil est une
véritable plateforme collaborative de
formations francophones
aujourd'hui nos sessions de formation
sont principalement en ligne du fait des
contraintes sanitaires de déplacement je
pense que la langue française c'est
avant tout un trait d'union entre les
gens et ça cela se fait au travers de la
rencontre donc j'espère que 2021
permettra de réinitier cette rencontre
allez maintenant on met ce département
français et européens placés au coeur de
l'océan indien a donc son réseau
d'outils de formation à la francophonie
une trace de la coopération c'est
l'histoire de la maison ce sont les
femmes malgaches qui sont venus pour
leur formation et le soir avant de se
coucher elle broutait les abécédaires
pour les centres c'est notre histoire
qui va donc ça veut dire que ces deux
structures étaient complémentaires qui
répondent à la francophonie pourquoi pas
ce que c'est un espace de liberté
la francophonie c'est la culture on
vient avec sa culture ses préoccupations
serre elles sont imaginés à ses
obsessions et on a la langue française
en commun 2021
en fait les 100 ans de baudelaire
souvent pourra s'amuser
les hommes d'équipage prennent des
albatros le français points d'accrochage
de la multiculturalité de linda océanie
ces outils prouve que c'est possible et
qu'ensemble ils préparent l'avenir de
cette région du monde
les à celle affaire de tous donc un lieu
qui nous permet de se réunir questionné
et tenter de trouver ensemble des
questions
ces outils comme ça doivent être portés
par tout le monde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]